six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number our next caller is from the
a21 for area code caller from to14 tell
us who you are and what's on your mind
today
hi David it's Frank macwrite in Dallas
Texas
oh hey Frank what's going on nothing
much so I have question about kind of
like the racial issues that are going on
in the White House and not just in the
White House but just the opposite or the
lack of opportunity now when I see
someone like say for example Stephen
Miller who's clearly an unsavory
character you know and watch him you
know watch him claw his way from you
know the the reputation that he had in
college and that all that stuff and he
still clawed his way into the White
House somehow and no matter what happens
this guy can walk off and go I was in
the White House that's that's pretty
major accomplishment but you know the
way that the system is set up I'm you
know I'm a mixed background so I would
say like I I look like Obama but nobody
ever says you know Obama was the first
mixed president they say he was the
first black president and that's how it
works
sure so Oh growing up on 4048 now
growing up over the years I you know
been able to be successful in my career
but I seen the you know the a lot of the
challenges and its really the
opportunities like that aren't presented
to people of color or even women I was
talking to a woman last night and that
hey you could go out and do this you can
be in this and in the industry that I
meant at the offices that I've worked
I've worked with some very major
companies samsung into it don't see a
lot of diversity and I think about that
rank I mean so can you give me some
existed to hear in what ways do you feel
that what you said of course is is
actually a mixed-race background but
perceptually you're seen as a as a black
man in the way that Obama is how do you
feel that that has impacted some of the
opportunities you've had well I can
definitely tell you things that people
have said
I definitely get the what are you
question right and because of my
complexion a lot of place a lot of times
people think I'm Latino but I still get
the stereotypes that go along with that
like when I go to New York City
everybody thinks Puerto Ricans think I'm
Puerto Rican and they speak Spanish to
me and it's just how it is but um I I
you know I've seen people's attitude
change when they find out what I am I I
can honestly say and I be I think I
would be silly to ignore the fact that I
think I have not gotten jobs because of
it real um oh absolutely I yeah I know
we don't have time but I can tell you
examples like pure examples that are so
very blatant but the thing is too is
that I you know in the in this I guess
my question is like how do we get who do
we you know who do we vote for - to make
truly quality because I I don't
understand how the government doesn't
get it that if everybody is doing well
or if we can give everybody the
opportunity to do well our economy is
going to be better everything is going
to be a lot better right but it just
doesn't seem especially with this
administration that's like if if you're
already rich then you're good to go yeah
other than that you're on your own well
a couple thoughts I mean this is a big
issue Frank but I think one thing is the
the change is probably not going to come
from the White House down I think that
it probably needs to come from other
places and I just don't think that while
the who's in the Oval Office certainly
can set the direction of the country and
one way or the other but I think if
we're looking to the Oval Office it
sounds almost libertarian of me to say
it but I wouldn't look to the Oval
Office to deal with the issues of racial
discrimination and inequality etc the
other thing is we need to get an
agreement we need to see eye-to-eye on
equality of opportunity because there's
a lot of people on the right and
so-called classical liberals who say
we're for equality of opportunity but
then they describe a situation that
isn't really equality of opportunity and
so if you can imagine two people someone
born into a wealthy suburban situation
and someone else born into a very poor
urban circumstance both whom have the
same potential based on genetics for
example right they don't have the same
equality of opportunity that's not the
quality of opportunity to fact the fact
the kind of give away their netic I'm
just not presented as equal equal
opportunity it's just not yes it's not
so I think that that's unless we come to
an agreement about what equality of
opportunity is it's also going to be
tough to move forward but big issues
Frank and I appreciate you bringing them
up thanks for taking the call Dave all
right no problem whatsoever